c'est
vraiment pas beau pas c'est vous qui
est calme et bouge en train de parler on
peut en placer une ou pas d'ailleurs si
c'est gentil j'ai laissé parler
l'amalgamme que vous êtes en train de
faire il est totalement dramatique parce
que moi je dénonce ce qui s'est passé
dans ces années et qui sont ces c'est
horrible ce qui s'est pas d'envolées
relaxe en train de finir on voulait
relativise il devrait alors tennis et
olivo lead alors on ne peut jamais et
vous relativisez jeu relatif pour la
visite de mikari tu n'y vas pas entendu
quand il ya eu d'autres caricatures pour
la version
essayée d'instrumentaliser les choses
pour
les cotisations cautionne ce qui s'est
passé on a fait
dérouler exterminer les arènes qui
essaye de les sauver je
ça c'est l'amalgamé ball à la bombe et à
l'émotion d'un autre gars parce que là
clairement les accusations font par
contre vous est ce grave je ne crois
sincèrement le monsieur mais je pense
sincèrement pas que vous êtes un
antisémite jeu je pense ouais je vois
que vous avez quand je dis que ça a été
maladroit et j'irais pas jusqu'a dire
que vous relatez visibles juste c'est
maladroit et c'est pour ça que ça choque
et c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
une limite mais je n'ai pas non plus
jusqu'à dire que vous relatez à faire
une caricature
il faut pas insulter l'histoire mais je
veux pas me faire de procès sur une
personne je ne vous connaissais très
maladroit a dit michel roja merci
d'avoir eu dans mes yeux que je n'étais
pas antisémite je vous le confirme
c'est une caricature c'est fait pour
forcer le trait et pour engager des
débats publics alors évidemment je sais
bien que la france ça n'a rien à voir
avec l'allemagne nazie a évidemment mais
c'est fait pour forcer le trait moi ça
j'en veux à emmanuel macron ses
errements il le 12 juillet l'annoncé le
passé dit m quelques semaines avant il
disait il n'y aura jamais de pas
salutaire pour le restaurant dans les
hôtels etc etc je vois voilà j'ai voulu
choquer mais pas insulter qui que ce
soit moi monsieur cdg dans mon entourage
des gens qui sont revenus des camps ils
sont très âgés maintenant ils m'ont dit
si tu veux on vient au tribunal dira que
dire que tu es notre ami ça va de soi
enfin vous rien